the Yankees are gonna go 162 and
hopefully you don't believe me Ryan
Dempster is here to confirm that from of
course and will be network 213 on your
DirecTV Ryan am i right I don't think
they're gonna go 162 and oh um what's
more what's more like really close what
like like what maybe like 140 in 22 no
what a great opening day huh and what a
way to start it Giancarlo Stanton
showing up in town and and doing what he
does best and putting on a show
hitting them hitting the ball I said
last night a country kilometer up there
in Canada so it was uh it was pretty fun
to watch and and pretty dangerous lineup
they're gonna be they're gonna be a
pleasure to watch oh yeah snark aside
Ryan of course obviously I'm just being
the guy that that that you know
overreact opening day and the incessant
coverage which undoubtedly we will get
about America's most popular team coming
up I I truly understand but as a pitcher
here how do you work around those two in
the middle of the lineup well yeah I
think that's that's the key is you can't
really work around those guys I was
saying yesterday what do you do you put
them on like and then the next guy is
capable hitting it out and then Gary
Sanchez behind them and the next guy
behind it you have to be aggressive and
it's like it's like kind of like the the
box or mentality your face and you know
the big dog and you just think and
you're gonna you're gonna outlast them
and wait around till he shows some
weakness you're gonna be in trouble you
have to go hit him in the face first and
so you have to go in and you know be
aggressive pump the strike zone get
ahead in the count because if you could
behind the count to these guys and you
they're gonna do some huge damage and
they you know the right-handed pitchers
with good stuff and good sliders I think
they're they're gonna be susceptible to
some strikeouts but when they're facing
lefties unless it's a really really
tough lefty you got to hit your spots
otherwise you're you're you're in
trouble man you're just stopped it's not
gonna pay off for you
talking to Ryan Dempster of course from
MLB tonight 6 o'clock Eastern Time on
MLB Network Yankees Blue Jays 7 o'clock
coming up this evening the other guy and
we saw him on the screen there Ryan
was was Aaron judge did did we I don't
say exposed but the way the way that
Aaron judge was striking out granted it
happened in the regular season as well
but in the postseason Maynooth ink he's
more susceptible to that I guess what
I'm saying I did can he be pitched to
better than then then Giancarlo Stanton
um I just think the fact there's a
little bit younger and a little bit less
experienced and you see that with young
guys you know when you look at the
playoffs and you look at what happens is
you get down to the better teams and
with the better teams you have the
better pitchers and those guys execute
better so as his career goes on and as
he gets that fast and he gets experience
facing these guys and knowing how guys
are gonna pitch them and watching how
they pitched Giancarlo that I think
those things will will really pay off
huge dividends for him he's a home run
hitter home run hitter strike out not
many guys are the Albert Pujols is where
they hit 45 but strike out 50 times a
year um I think you're looking at a
situation that the more at-bats he gets
the better off he's gonna be and I think
having Giancarlo and seeing that and
understanding how guys are pitching them
will help benefit both of them but I
mean he saw it he struggled after the
all-star break last year and then he
came back on fire in September and you
can have ups and downs but I could see
him going out there and having maybe not
home run wise but you know getting on
base and average wise having a better
year than he did last year Ryan you
pitched for opening days to for the
Marlins back-to-back years to for the
Cubs back-to-back years what's that like
it's great and I know you know people
would see it as overrated but for a
player you do all this work in the
offseason then you get to spring
training and it's it's just go time it's
like the bells ring and here we go now
all these things that we work so hard
for in this base that I set upon myself
to be ready to go a whole season has
come into a culmination and it's
starting and to be the guy that leads
that off to go out there and start an
opener you know it's always going to be
a sold a sold out show that the house is
packed every time no matter where you
are you know and I think I said it last
night on the show my favorite one was at
Olympic Stadium and
mm - just in Canada I'm Canadian guy at
home pitching against the Expos and it
was sold out crowd with those who've
Allah's or whatever they collude ilysm
mortgage was boohoo's vuvuzela right
vuvuzela yeah yeah sounds like the
pitcher for the Rockies but you know
it's just it's a blast and it really is
and then it's you know back to work the
next day but it's it's kind of what
you're waiting for all year for the
stats to matter you know you look at
baseball cards no matter how many look
at there's not any stats on the back for
spring training and so now it now it all
matters and just an honor to take the
ball for your team and start at all well
said Ryan Dempster the Nationals have an
opening day today after a rain now
granted they are on the road they are in
Cincinnati but it will be a sellout
crowd there because it always is for the
Reds on opening day a lot of people
think it's Bryce Harper's year the
Nationals year to represent the National
League do you think however this is
Bryce Harper's final opening day with
the nets I don't know I've thought about
that because you know you see him as a
national draft and you know number one
overall and come up and be the superstar
winning MVP and I'm know they're gonna
try and do everything they possibly can
to keep them but at the same time once
you become a free agent a lot of people
trying to take you out to dinner and
wine and dine in and have you come play
for them and sometimes somebody makes an
offer you can't refuse and I know
there's a lot of teams that would love
to have Bryce Harper all across the
league I'm sure all thirty would
probably 25 of those there he's out of
their price range but the Nationals they
have great ownership they have a lot of
money there and I could see him coming
back and being back there and signing a
deal in Washington ya know he loves it
there so I don't think I think he might
I think you might come back there at the
end of it all what about out here in LA
Oh tani 1 for 5 yesterday but but
hitting eighth which is a little bit odd
for a d-h but you want him in the lineup
do you think that he can withstand the
rigors of of pitching and da Qing
I don't know and I wish I could give you
yes I wish I could give you know I just
know how hard it is to pitch in the big
leagues and I definitely know how hard
it is to hit because I wasn't a very
good hitter and so it's an extremely
hard thing to do at this level where
guys are constantly making adjustments
you know in Japan you're pitching once a
week you're not facing the best of the
best pitchers day in and day out where
you are here and I think that he has the
talent you know you look at the teams
and the people that were going after him
these guys aren't idiots they're
baseball geniuses they got top-notch
Scouts and everybody says all these
tremendous things you see the video he
throws up near 100 miles an hour he's
he's got power
I think I think there's a possibility if
you look at players out there that could
he could I just think it's a huge
challenge and maybe you know I
especially - not only doing that but
then coming to a new country where they
don't speak your language where you got
a culture shift where you got different
things that you have to get used to it's
just a lot for them and I think it might
have some bumps in the roads at first
but I think that there's a possibility
he could do some special things and I
think spring training was just a tool
for him to get ready for the season as
we saw he goes out there gets a base hit
had a couple good at-bats he looked
better yesterday than he did in any
Spring Training game yeah sure and
that's part of it too
isn't it Ryan just you you see this with
position players coming from Japan or
from Korea for that matter there is
there's a process to get acclimated and
not everybody as Ichiro coming in and
getting 200 hits right out of the gate
and when you throw that into it I almost
wonder if the Angels would would be
better off if they just said pitch and
every now and then will give you a bat
but don't worry about that now yeah I
think but what happens is when you make
promises to a guy who chooses to come
there you can't sure a decision so it is
hard I remember when Fukudome came over
from Japan in that first month of April
at the Walker game-tying home run
against the Brewers up Gagne three-run
homer and then you know he's coming up
with big hits makes the Ulster team and
then it the leak caught up to him you
know and that's what happens in the big
leagues it's adjustment central a people
are constantly making them you have
scouting everywhere you got people in
the stands
cameras on you and they will find a
weakness and exploit it and you have to
find a way to realize when they're
making those adjustments on you and
counter those adjustments like a chess
match always so if he can do that and
understand that make those adjustments
then he can have some success but you're
right it's a it's a huge change there's
been one each row and that's it yeah
this kid this kids really special and
he's got a he's got ability for sure by
the way to just it was weird last night
watching Ichiro great to have him back
by the way in Seattle but to see him in
left field and he took his hat off at
one point they they had a shot of him in
left field and and the gray hair out
there it was kind of jarring but it's
awesome to see him there and but it was
odd to see him taking out late innings
for a defensive replacement like I see
the best defensive right fielder for
years yeah his ability to climb a wall
to make a throw to do whatever and he's
you know it is awesome to see him back
in Seattle to you know probably finish
up his major-league career here who
knows if he ends up going to Japan and I
always joke around he's kind of like
Benjamin Button ya never get old us I
thought the same thing last night was
the first time I was like whoa he's a
little great yeah he looks a little bit
older but you know he sets a tremendous
example for his teammates how to prepare
for a game and he still has the ability
man to put the barrel the bat on the
baseball yep like almost like a tennis
ball he's just kind of dropping it over
the net or dropping it over the head of
the first baseman and ever he needs to
to get on base Ryan Dempster before we
go our poll question Chris can can you
update the poll question because it
actually Ryan involves one of your
former teams here
the Marlins want you to weigh in Chris
go ahead all right Ryan what would be
the bigger upset Loyola Chicago beating
Michigan tomorrow
Tiger Woods winning the Masters the
Browns making the playoffs this season
or the Marlins finishing with a winning
record well I've been watching the
basketball tournament loyal has got as
good a shot as any team to win the whole
thing the way they've been going on with
you
Tiger Woods if something specials happen
in there I don't know what it is but
something's going on and I'm gonna be at
the Masters so I'm looking forward to
seeing this game's rocker yep yeah
absolutely
and then the Browns and they're the
Browns but eventually you got to win
so I'm going to last one the biggest
surprise would be if the Marlins had a
five I mean they just don't have the and
then you lose your catcher and you lose
them yeah and you lose all these guys
but they got some great young pieces
that eventually down the road and I'm
never doubting a thing ever that Derek
Jeter touches because he finds a way to
make things work and not just work work
at a high level so eventually they will
be in a very good spot it's just not
going to be this year
yeah and I'm with you that was Ryan I
had yet to get my answer to the question
on the air but but that that was going
to be my answer as well I don't know the
Tigers gonna win it but I wouldn't be
stunned the Browns you know teams go
from worst to first in the NFL every
year although this would be monumental
it's just it's probably got to be the
Marlins yeah yeah and maybe tonight 6
p.m. Eastern Time leading into the
Yankees in the Blue Jay 7 o'clock on MLB
Network he started for opening days he
won a World Series in 2013 with the Red
Sox Ryan Dempster thanks for taking the
time I don't know today's crazy
appreciate it
hey absolutely guys have a have a great
day have enjoy your weekend likewise
write down the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience